Okay, one of my favorite parts about our signature
segment "Designed By Drew" is helping redesign spaces
for those who give back to everybody else and nobody works
harder, supporting others than first responders.
(audience cheers)
So, Cat Lewis
has made history or her-stry, as we now say
as the first career female firefighter in the city
of Long Beach, New York.
She and her fellow firefighters put their lives on the line
every single day.
I was lucky enough to meet them, take a look.
(siren sounding)
As a young girl,
I always wanted to be a firefighter.
My name is Catherine Lewis,
and most people here call me Cat.
The Long Beach Fire Department has existed for almost
a hundred years, but I'm the first career
female firefighter.
A lot of people are used to seeing
the fire truck drive by and seeing four guys in the back
but now, they see my ponytail
and they immediately light up with a smile.
She's gonna show so many young girls
that anything could be accomplished.
She broke the glass ceiling.
Cat is like a daughter to me.
I admire pretty much everything about her.
She's exceptional, the fact that she's a division one
college athlete, she has a master's degree.
She crushed the entrance exam, she did amazing
on the physical agility.
You know, there were days where we didn't have
an instructor for PT, and Cat became the unofficial
PT instructor for the entire academy of all men.
Not only does she holds her own, she excels.
The firehouse is a home away from home.
We definitely spent a lot of time together
in the den. We spend holidays, birthdays, anniversaries
at the firehouse.
The fire service is not just a brotherhood now. Its
more like a brotherhood and sisterhood, It's a family.
I couldn't be more proud of all the people
that I work with. I know that they're going to do
everything that they can to protect the city of Long Beach.
I think as a firefighter, most people get into the job
because they want to save lives. We're here to save lives,
but we're here to help people on their worst day.
I would love for young girls to see me and think, oh wow,
I could be a firefighter too.
(Audience cheering)
Oh Cat,
any man, woman or child is going to watch
you Cat and dream and think about possibilities
and hopefully you know, trying to rise
to the occasion the way that you have.
And also your family, the other members from the Long Beach
Fire Department are here today.
Hi guys
Why did you want to be this female first responder
set the bar, set the tone.
Yeah. So, I mean, I've always wanted to be a firefighter.
Growing up, I didn't know many female firefighters.
So I, I view it as a privilege right now to be a role model
for young girls and young kids. Just see, you know,
you could do whatever you want to do as long as you put
hard work into it and persevere.
(Applause)
Now, you guys
we talked about how you spend time with the people
you work with in ways that, you know, completely equal,
if not sometimes tips the scale of the time you spend with
your family. And it does make you a family
and a family deserves a beautiful space,
especially one that takes care of everybody else.
So, well, we have a little fun surprise.
check it out.
(Cheers)
Hi, Cat and company. How you guys doing ?
Hey Drew
I like surprises.
(laughs)
I am in awe
of what you do,
So I'm not even going to pretend like I could do what
you do,
but I do love design.
I was looking around your space and I was wondering
if you guys would be open to doing a Design by Drew,
which is the segment we do here on our show
and I could make over your space?
No way, oh my gosh.
Yes. We need it.
Drew, we need it.
I think your place has so much soul
and it does have really good cozy vibes.
So I'd love to try and make it something that feels fresh
and new, but really keep the personality
that's already there.
Can you do Frat house leftover chic?
(Chuckles)
The place is built
I believe in the early seventies
and other than a couple coats of paint over the years
it really hasn't had that much.
I'd like to have your back in any capacity,
the way you have everybody else's back.
That's so cool, thank you so much Drew.
I can't wait to get started.
This table,
we want to preserve that it's really special.
Yeah, that has to stay.
But we need new chairs, I like this reference
because this felt kind of like
hotel vibes.
It's almost like a hotel lobby-esque
type of field that's elevated.
And also there are shipping problems in the country
with the ports and some of the stuff we were liking
originally is just simply not available.
So these are the two floor plans
that I had created.
I do like some individual chairs in case they
don't want to buddy up.
Sometimes they're there for days and weeks and they
have to spend the night there.
So like they want a little break away from each other.
So I thought this was a nice way to kind of break things up.
I love it.
I'm liking this,
this would be a very swanky lounge.
I can't think of anyone who deserves it more.
I'm not going to let you down, It's going to be beautiful.
(Audience cheering)
Um, okay. We are going to go
to a quick commercial break
but I gotta tell you my design partner-in-crime
Mikel Welch, I'm really excited about what we came up with.
(Bright music)